there's a good chance that some of your
first experiences with the dark souls
franchise include friends talking about
how amazing and/or difficult the
gameplay is I know the only real reason
I got into the games at first was
because I had some friends who said that
the gameplay was so good that it ruined
all of their RPGs I wanted to disprove
them looking back at it though the
gameplay probably is as good as they
said it was or at least pretty close
Dark Souls is a series that has a lot of
great aspects though it really falls
back on one core feature good gameplay
in combat while things like the
soundtracks and the atmosphere really
help bring the games to a higher level
what connects the souls born games and
ensures their quality is how it feels to
move and fight through each game without
this uniform gameplay Dark Souls really
wouldn't be Dark Souls
let's first take a look at overall
gameplay design and then a closer view
on combat specifically
the main reason the gameplay shines so
greatly is because of how fluid it is
running through the world of Dark Souls
is one continuous stream in Dark Souls
one you play the first half of the game
without any fast travel option this
means that the world has to give you
options and paths to connect you from
the hub to every early to mid-game boss
and it does so without needing any
loading screens sure you can homeward
bone for convenience and obviously the
game has to reload after any deaths but
you can stroll from Firelink shrine to
undead burg to the undead parish to sift
back to the undead burg to the depths to
blight town and back to the shrine
without any necessary loading screens
obviously in a practical sense you won't
do this so fully in your first couple of
times through the game but still that's
a huge stream of game playing combat
without any break or change to be fair
the most recent game doesn't have quite
this level of connection the hub of Dark
Souls 3 also named Firelink shrine is
locked away behind a loading screen it's
in a different area of the game than the
main world and this is a popular
criticism of the game it takes away from
the beloved fluidity even still the game
does maintain a stronger connection than
most comparing it to another popular
game let's look at destiny destiny takes
you back to the hub world after every
mission to progress to the next this
means that continuing through the main
story takes you through a series of
loading screens that break up gameplay
every time you make significant progress
and the hub zone is third-person
compared to the games more default
first-person combat mode and even in
that combat mode you have yet another
level of different gameplay that being
the sparrow the sparrows our vehicles
required to travel the longer distances
that are found throughout most of the
outer hub areas of course destiny is a
very different game so things like this
have their reasons and these different
levels of gameplay can be a very good
thing I'm not trying to get into a big
debate about all the pros and cons of
these various features and their
appropriateness for specifically destiny
I just want to highlight the difference
because if we return to Dark Souls we
don't have any of that no interruptions
to take us away from the action at least
not nearly to the same magnitude what
really makes possible this lack of
interruptions is a clever use of world
design and backtracking shortcuts which
lets the world enter we
itself and allow for the player to more
often than not complete areas and
connect back to previous ones without
having to simply turn around and run the
same route in Reverse with no enemies
it's essentially a much more developed
version of the idea that we can see more
simply done in Skyrim's dungeons at the
end of almost every dungeon in Skyrim a
secret door or something similar reveals
that you're right near the start of the
dungeon and allows you to leave the
dungeon without having to directly
backtrack everywhere you just went
through it's an appealing feature that
is generally met with a pleasant
surprise at least the first few times it
is Skyrim unfortunately used this too
much as a cookie cutter recipe and too
many dungeons have this exact formula of
exit and it got monotonous and kind of
repetitive
it wasn't something new after the first
four times however the souls Bourne
series takes this whole idea to a much
higher level by implementing a more
complex version of this throughout the
entire worlds of their games and it's
able to avoid the monotony found in
Skyrim by keeping their workarounds
creative and surprising because they had
a whole world to work with to make these
workarounds there are more options than
are present at the end of just a dungeon
which is really the only place we saw it
used heavily in Skyrim using a myriad of
tools Dark Souls brings a more
continuous experience that facilitates
deeper immersion in the gameplay
now that we've taken a wide look let's
dive a bit deeper into looking solely at
the highly revered combat of Dark Souls
first a broader view of the whole system
and then more specific interactions
first a look at how some other games
handled combat and a lot of other games
fight sequences are often accompanied by
an emerging soundtrack and maybe even a
different fight Motors stance an example
of this is a recent RPG that I really
love The Witcher 3 Geralt the
protagonist of the series as a different
move set went in and out of combat and
can only do certain tasks in each mode
like only being able to climb ladders in
non fight mode when combat begins in The
Witcher the atmosphere adjusts itself
and combat music swells up the game
wants you to now Zone in and prepare to
fight I think that this causes a rift
between combat gameplay and non-combat
gameplay like exploration this
distinction can be done well and it can
be a fairly fluid mesh between the
different modes and gameplays but
regardless of how well it's done it does
break up the game and kind of
compartmentalize it into different mode
however I'm not trying to point this out
as some flaw for The Witcher different
games benefit from different things as I
said of destiny I just want to point out
that noticing this difference can again
let us appreciate the uniqueness of Dark
Souls and the benefits of that
uniqueness because in Dark Souls you're
always in fight mode in Dark Souls 1
enemies can even follow you into
Firelink shrine which is the supposed
hub and safe zone of the game in Dark
Souls 3 is Firelink shrine there's less
of this because enemies are barred from
entering and it's separated from most of
the world but for the most part you're
always have a threat of danger because
this fight mode is always on there's no
change when combat starts no special
music there's no gameplay difference
between walking down a path and fighting
an enemy on that same path the only
feasible change in game control is the
optional enemy lock-on and even so many
players end up not even using that as
they opt for their own control of the
camera without the lock-on unlike other
games you're not limited or restricted
in any way whether or not you're in
combat you have the same movement
capabilities and attack types at any
time in the game if you want a heavy
attack in front of you you can't
regardless of if there's an
you want to roll instead of running or
run instead of rolling sure go ahead
I think this is an example of a feature
that's gotten better as the games have
progressed Dark Souls 3 in my opinion
has the most freedom of rolling or
running exactly whenever you want to
regardless of lock-on it's a little bit
more clunky I think of narsil 1 having
the same move set at all times helps
unite the time you're not fighting to
the time you are furthering the games
overall cohesiveness because you always
have complete control of your character
another aspect that really helps this is
that there's almost no ambient music in
these games the hub will generally have
a theme and every boss has a pretty
powerful soundtrack to accompany it but
past that there's not really much
exploring or fighting mobs doesn't have
a unique soundtrack or any at all
most areas have no music playing the
only audio is from what's actually
happening real-time in-game the footstep
patters the armor shuffles the sword
clangs the majority of the time you
adventure and fight is accompanied at
least audio-wise
only by these sounds and the sounds of
your enemies this fits with the theme of
continuity specific combat music is
another aspect of the special fight
modes we talked about that are found in
other games like The Witcher because
Dark Souls lacks this it's furthered in
its fluidity lacking distinctive
fighting music for most of the fights in
the game bridges all those moments
together with the other fighting moments
and also with all the other times spent
in between these fighting moments in
which the player might be exploring or
looting chests or salt and puzzles
now let's narrow down to the more
specific interact the most prevalent
gameplay in Dark Souls is had with the
close combat striking and thrust
markings
swords beards and such obviously there
is other gameplay mechanics such as
magic and pyromancy but because this is
the majority of the gameplay that's what
I'm going to be focusing on what I think
speaks to the fluidity here and only
exists because of the fluidity we
previously talked about striking with a
sword against an enemy has no effect on
the enemy until the sword actually hits
they will continue to try and attack you
all the way up to the point where you're
hit actually lands this is opposed to
the more restrictive fixed animation
interactions which we can see a lot in
the recent Batman games and just some
extent in games like The Witcher and
even Skyrim with its anime
killshot the animation interactions do
definitely have their purpose though
they are really cinematic in the batman
games you're supposed to be Batman The
Dark Knight and as a result you should
be doing the huge acrobatics and jumps
and leaps between criminals to beat them
down and in Skyrim the final kill shots
do give a variety of satisfying endings
to various situations and they're really
only employed at the end of fights to
finish off enemies but while these can
be cinematic and enhance the user
experience they do take away some
control from the player in Batman you're
not really telling Batman to perform all
those spins and you nastic feats you're
pressing one button to counter or
continue a combo and he's doing all of
these acts in response in the meantime
this has the chance to take away some of
the connection the player has in the
game which might be OK for a game in
which you're taking the role of a very
pre-established character like Batman
but it wouldn't make a lot of sense in
Dark Souls where you're just some
no-name so it's a good and fitting thing
the Dark Soul steers clear of these
things and even when it does employ them
it keeps it simple the most common
examples of these and Dark Souls that I
can think of our backstabs andropause
four-post I don't know and these are
generally only one or two simple strikes
nothing that makes the player feel that
their character is really doing anything
on their own without player input or
player commands and even killing the
ancient wyvern which is the biggest
example of this fix animation attacking
the franchise that I can think of is
also just one plunging strike into its
head sure there's an animation that
follows your character isn't doing
anything special like in Batman Dark
Souls avoidance of a prevalent use of
this feature keeps the combat feeling
very direct one comparison that just
came to mind when I was writing this
probably because I've recently started
playing it a bit more is super smash
bros melee this is a game that has
maintained a pro scene despite being 15
years old and having two successors
because it's gameplay movement and
combat are just so good it's obviously a
very different game as a whole but it
has a lot of similarities to the stuff
that we talked about in Dark Souls over
this video there aren't separate modes
it's all just one fighting mode and the
game's combat and fighting interactions
are some of the best I think I've ever
seen looking at least it's the more
compelling
sighs interactions are all extremely
fluid responsive and precise down to the
frame and dark souls is able to bring a
lot of those same features into a much
bigger game that actually has a
narrative and obviously a whole lot more
features then smash bros melee the
combat is able to maintain the fluidity
that the overall gameplay sets up
allowing for yet another layer of it
because that means that all the
movements from fighting to not fighting
and back have no big breaks or
discontinuity the game's flow from one
zone to the next and from one fight
today
Dark Souls can be enjoyed so well
because it lets the player play the
gameplay of the game as much as we want
the largest stoppage by far of this has
to be the loading screens accompanied
with dying this could be put another way
by saying that because we are the only
ones responsible for our deaths ideally
at least we are the only ones keeping
ourselves from enjoying the game and his
continued stream of fluid gameplay and
combat obviously the souls born
franchise has a lot more than just this
one feature that makes it so beloved and
praised but I honestly think that this
core feature is paramount for the series
and is the real unifying thread between
all the games it's what has kept us all
coming back for more and I can't wait to
see it from software delivers this again
in their future titles well I didn't
write an ending little spiel but I guess
I should do one thank you everybody for
watching this video if you have enjoyed
it please continue to stick around
because I like making videos like this
and if you like this video you probably
like my other videos
[Music]
you please share
[Music]
I'm gonna say three times
[Music]